[Music]
in sounds familiar news I know that song
twinkle twinkle little star sounds like
abcdefg another one submitted by love
YouTube so awkward about I don't know
why I feel like not reciprocally I love
you know I love you guys but I just feel
weird when you read it next to me mmm Oh
cuz it feels like balls loves you and
you love her back that's [ __ ] up no
because this ism because I take it like
I overthink it and then I feel like just
that was barely a second how did you
overthink that I feel like there's
someone thinking like she wrote it
because that law being you dude
how did you even come up with that that
is crazy you know why cuz I would do
that I don't get accused of it [ __ ] I'd
be like big love Joe [ __ ] ball sacks the
size of a bull dangle you need some self
esteem there's two conversations going
on
you like the balls I didn't hear what
was happening with her I was just saying
who cares if someone accuses you that's
great for you thank you I care too much
about what other people think because
TIFF is a caring person that's why she
cares so it's like you care a lot about
people but you also care about their
[ __ ] stupid-ass thoughts I do too
much I need to be that's why she's
caring I was deep like Tiffany felt like
she's like not deserving of this love
know she's sensitive but it's positive
because it's like you could count on her
to go ah when you're like whatever but
you can't count on you can't count on
Bart to go
for me when you heard or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] feelings ourselves like the
enemy say I'm [ __ ] sensitive as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
about other people they go oh you must
be hurt because they know that [ __ ] you
know and then it's like but then but
then people like Bart would you just
continue breathing and he would not
notice yeah it's like wouldn't that
grandpa had those veins that we thought
were tattoos and then we couldn't stop
laughing yeah but do we need we need the
sensitive people in the world we need
them YouTube time around to pollinate
you guys that's feelings and emotions
narcissistic guests have three minutes
it was all about
good job mastermind yeah no one Jesus
tits genius know how you pulled that one
off okay childish gambino is now
battling the allegation that this is
america was plagiarized you do not talk
about our national treasures that way
you talk about our national anthem like
that i know what if it sounds exactly
the same felt right oh then oh really
what what did you steal just [ __ ]
stealing from oh [ __ ] so I like already
knows is that what do you call it okay
you know what hip-hop used samples
consistently all the time they would
take James Brown songs Marvin Gaye
phones and they'll take bits and pieces
of the song and then make remix them
some of the best songs from like 90's
hip hop or just samples yeah oh you just
nuts
mm-hmm yeah like farside like five out
of ten of their only songs all of them
were loops it was fired it was awesome
but that's the art of hip-hop you're
supposed to do that hey we were so young
we never heard of those songs in the
first place yeah he'll still do that to
this day he's like oh that's my songs
I'm like no that was a cover of an
original dope ass that's Isley Brothers
that's the original
no that's bone thugs-n-harmony man now
like watch the song is gonna be like to
a tee with the gunshot the black chorus
and everything uh uh I mean no but they
do that for right now so right now
what's that what's that uh there's like
that Nicki Minaj song but it's like
basically now they're just doing 90
songs and they're just taking the hook
or doing [ __ ] like a mix of hot songs
and 10th in yeah yeah the snake there
anacondas one that's a sir mix-a-lot
[ __ ] booty shake booty booty I
wouldn't mind as long as I get the money
for it
it's site you bet off this is like I
don't get a royalty score itself
yeah but when you're 15 men being
original matters there's no such thing
as originality really anymore yeah
especially with the internet and
everybody's like what's called
influenced by something or somebody so
it's just a reiteration or something
that you had way like you're trying to
cover up some [ __ ] that you copied off
of other people no I I mean definitely
I'm an influencer of like Dave Chappelle
man I was just kidding man what the [ __ ]
I know the feeling now and you can't
when you want to roast them and he
doesn't care it's not hurt you damn it
we all though like when I first started
doing this you got offended at all stand
up like it was very reminiscent of early
Dave Chappelle and I caught myself all
that yo that's not your [ __ ] dude like
if you are gonna be influenced by
somebody you got to flip it up and not
Jack somebody style so it was like Dave
Chappelle Eddie Murphy it was very
reminiscent of that and I learned to cut
that [ __ ] out and trying to make my old
voice with the influence that they gave
me so we know how I know I'm original
cuz no one's that scoundrel as I am
[Music]
[Laughter]
delicious did unfinished as [ __ ] to even
using Mickey Mouse grub daddy what a
scrub daddy taking it you'll see it they
bit off you did
this is way before this is [ __ ] like
six seven ten years oh my god scrub
daddy copied you I'm told I'm an
original that is an original part on
Kwanzaa much is so [ __ ] up nobody's
gonna copy this are you ever gonna
finish its finish time you thought it
wasn't no it's a representation see it's
it's kind of hard to explain you decide
when it's done I understand it's done
you don't have black paint cuz that's
all you needed for the gloves and the
sunglass Joe he's done that's the
message
yes the message it's you don't finish
your [ __ ] basically always half-ass your
life yep well this guy actually he was
getting tanned by another Sun and not
those who has tan lines if you want to
take a picture with it you need to have
30k followers or above you gotta tag my
Instagram yep alright so back to tell
just gonna be no here so we're saying
that he copied okay well here's the
photo of them in case you guys forgot
who he was Donald Glover to tell this
Camino should be used to her apparently
copied a song called American Pharoah
from this this artist named chase Harley
chase Harley okay and so I'm gonna play
that was Kanye West dude I'm so nervous
y'all I'm so nervous my boy so you guys
have all heard this is America right
yeah so this is chase Harley's American
Pharoah which was uploaded two years ago
Oh
I mean there's a harmony and there's
like a choir and the drums are always
awesome oh my god the flow is so similar
even the content the delivery - you know
what though
I got some [ __ ] to say this happens in
music all that time yeah I know
professional musicians Wow that's Matt
similar it's like creepy similar yeah it
sounds like it could've came out of the
same okay I'll tell you what it is I'll
tell you what happened okay so what
happened exactly
even like a placement of the drops are
like very similar yeah even the drum
fills flows the same - yeah this part
lucify is endemic the delivery - yeah I
mean if he was talking about titties or
something that would be different though
I'm adding you to my Spotify
he's like an accountant like he didn't
blow up at that time I gotta give up my
dreams I'm sparking put dish sucks just
wrap and just flow as the beaten in the
beat isn't but that guy's dope he's good
[Music]
even the drop/add what the [ __ ] yeah
he's running through the hallway oh yeah
even though is a little weird I want to
write a rap song you do we have a lot I
know but I miss I miss our Styles like
early 2000s - we haven't really evolved
with the times I got to learn this rhyme
flow now carpool dude mr. OG McCloud
Jays he responded on Instagram was he
like what the hell dude so people so
this commenter said people were saying
Donald Glover but your song American
Pharoah with this is America what do you
think and then he says I always felt my
song inspired at lol from the first time
I heard it and then he responds someone
else saying yeah it's cool though glad
they liked my song it's all love oh what
a classy dude
Oh amazing like he's not planning on
suing or anything in + trying to to sue
someone for plagiarism it's it's a long
super expansion of changes in this is
America for he's not gonna win yeah they
have to have like these professionals to
come in and actually like dissect
everything and he also has to somehow
prove that childish gambino had access
to his song before like before he made
it or whatever but then it's just too
much process so someone from Gambia
Uncle Sam that we yep so we copied it
awesome that was pre-existing and
because we worked through a Chinese
company they said if you make ten
changes to the Hat they can't sue you so
we're like okay dope so we made our own
uncle Santa and we copied the [ __ ] out
of them and they can't sue us you're
childish gambino huh so yeah so heap
they probably know it's you like all
these people in the industry they
probably like oh if you change the song
like six times
you're unsuitable but you did it but you
didn't steal it because it was something
that existed yes
then because you use it and because of
the wear and tear like it like you
didn't come with one eye yeah yes you
didn't steal it
that's one of the changes but I also did
literally steal it from specially you
nearly stole it I stole it and then he
stole it what the [ __ ] dude like who
says [ __ ] like that hey I put it all out
there I'm vulnerable I'm a vulnerable
influencer vulnerable you just don't
give a [ __ ] roasted media alright so
challenges can be those co-manager at
his label called wolf in Rothstein so
his name is fam I have last names
towards to say the things man and so he
tweeted out well the Internet is a place
of no consequences I hate that Toronto
academics slash every white vlogger can
say something as gospel and y'all take
it this song is three years old and we
have Pro Tools files to prove it but
[ __ ] you and your moms and your future
fetuses stay blessed and that's a very
bad response and then he follows it with
you asked for a comment from this label
label this is it at pitchfork and both
of those Sweden's have been deleted cuz
they [ __ ] back cuz somebody probably
said yeah be fair though the amount of
like anger he was sore that I feel like
the song probably legitimately almost is
that old cuz like you don't get that mad
when like you when you're lying right
yeah I mean take that with a grain of
salt but I feel like that but this
happens all the time it depends on who
so when people think of artists right
they think they wrote the song they
wrote the lyrics they're did everything
you got a look at the credits yeah I
mean it could be that the producer had
the bright idea after hearing the song
and then he's like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
make a beat like this and then he he
pitches the beat to donald glover he's
like yo check this new song out alright
yeah
like this of the whole thing like y'all
heard Jaden Smith's album he and do
nothing can't do [ __ ] it was good album
this is a pretty decent that's all
production and like you don't always
know like who's taking what from what
yeah that's cuz like you see this a lot
in like comedy like what people have
like parallel jokes just because like it
had the same writer yeah like you'll see
it in like TV shows and everything else
and then like even like certain TV shows
like people get mad because all you took
my idea but there's there is just cause
of like parallel thought - yeah that was
a little hard oh that one was that
really very hard but like in common like
stand-up bits - even when I was doing
stand-up like I would do something and
there'll be like oh you took my stuff I
was like but my bit was from like four
years ago
you just started standing up so how did
I steal from you you know it's [ __ ]
crazy when we went to the Kevin Hart
concert Kevin said mother [ __ ] I've
noticed like I have some friends that
are improv actors and like sometimes I
guess they'll just hear something I'm
passing and then later on we'll be like
filming a video or doing some mannequins
all right yeah and like they don't think
anything of it and I'm not like on
calling them out but yeah it's not a big
fan you know that he's like consuming
logs JK content so I headline did he
like maybe was the few interactions that
I had with him sneaked in because you
guys sneaked into me and then it stuck
over there you say murder no maybe he's
lurking on our instagrams oh that's true
he said either like mother [ __ ] I'm not
an [ __ ] like some JK ass [ __ ] I'm
like mother ass we made it you're not
getting paper I don't care but if people
start using my word though mother [ __ ]
and that's the best you oh you'd anyway
music right now and you couldn't but
that's different okay
[Music]